à
[Musique]
elles sont de retour les guinguettes de
versailles rempile pour une deuxième
édition
installé sur 500 mètres carrés derrière
l'ancienne poste de l'avenue de paris
elles peuvent accueillir en plein air
près de 500 personnes à une centaine de
mètres du château ce qu'on peut faire
ici c'est un véritable lieu de vie donc
ce qu'on peut faire ici c'est venir déjà
entre amis en famille ou même salle et
c'est profiter d'un bar dans food truck
d'un espace chill et bien sûr d'une
piste de danse qui est maintenant
disponible
ce projet festif a été imaginé par le
collectif hop nerfs en partenariat avec
la ville de versailles
l'objectif c'est de répondre en fait à
la demande que les jeunes nous ont
exprimé depuis maintenant vraiment un
bout de temps qu'ils aient un espace un
peu de liberté un peu libre et en même
temps totalement totalement sécurisé
hall en plus voilà faire la fête malgré
les restes le malgré les restrictions
sanitaires
l'événement permet de mettre en avant
des commerçants locaux des dizaines
d'artistes du secteur peuvent également
se produire cet été devant un public
partout et trop bien versailles c'est
pas non plus une ville qui bouge
énormément et du coup c'est vrai que ces
endroits là avec vous et beaucoup et
c'est hyper bien avoir la chance d'être
sur scène ce dimanche 4 juillet le
cocktail musique locale et des tentes a
l'air de séduire
ils étaient plusieurs dizaines à venir
passer du temps dans cette guinguette
malgré des conditions climatiques
aléatoires
ja versailles ces petits donc tout le
monde se connaît donc c'est sympa tu va
croiser des groupes que t'as pas vu
depuis six mois un an la musique elle
est bonne et voilà c'est pour ça qu'on
aime bien c'est convivial un peu toute
la famille à les enfants les ados et les
guinguettes de versailles sont ouverts
tous les week-ends jusqu'au 26 septembre
recule pause pendant les premières
semaines du mois d'août
l'entrée est libre
[Musique]